You mess with time it tends to mess back
you'll see.
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my brand new marvel video
for the huge
villain they just announced it's a big
avengers level villain with connections
to fantastic four the x-men characters
all the stuff that's happening in marvel
phase 4 and marvel phase 5.
you mess with time it tends to mess back
that iron man quote from avengers
endgame
is never more important than it is right
now if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe
to get all the videos we'll do a new
amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know
what you're most hyped up about for
marvel phase four
so just starting with the big stuff
first number five deadline is reporting
that jonathan majors from lovecraft
country on hbo is the new kang the
conqueror of the marvel cinematic
universe
and his first major appearance in the
mcu is going to be as the main villain
of ant-man 3
then he'll go on to other avengers
crossover movies fantastic four movies
since obviously ant-man 3 is probably
the last ant-man solo movie
this is a huge deal for a bunch of
reasons and king the conqueror is a
long-time avengers villain with a very
deep connection to the fantastic four
the main avengers team like avengers 5
avengers 6 future team up movies
the young avengers that they're setting
up in all the other marvel phase 4
series and then the avengers in game
loki
spin-off series that marvel is doing on
disney plus next year
so this is connected to several other
things in addition to the new fantastic
four stuff in the mcu and the new x-men
stuff i know everyone wants to know
what's going on with that new fantastic
four movie that marvel is doing this is
a big part of that
but if you're not familiar with the
actor jonathan majors like i said his
big thing right now is lovecraft country
on hbo which is an adaptation of the hp
lovecraft mythology think eldritch
horrors from the multiverse
so obviously it's apropos of the quantum
realm the multiverse time travel
everything that they're doing in marvel
phase 4 marvel phase 5.
the actor also has a connection to
chadwick boseman in black panther he
actually just co-starred with chadwick
boseman
in his last on-screen appearance in the
movie defy bloods earlier this year
that's not a marvel movie it's just a
movie that chadwick boseman made last
year before his health took a turn for
the worse and he passed away
i've already done a couple of chadwick
boseman black panther tribute videos may
he rest in power
in black panther 2 movie videos about
the future that franchise in the mcu so
i will link those at the end of this and
in the description below
but number four there are several
reasons why marvel is using kang the
conqueror as the main villain of ant-man
3.
the first one obviously being he's a
huge character from the comics super
powerful
and super deep cut they really want to
get you to go see ant-man 3 so they're
going to try and put as much big stuff
in there as possible
this time around they won't have an
avengers movie lead-in teaser like they
did with avengers infinity war like
come see how this sets up avengers
endgame you have to see this to know
what happens next
so they have to come up with some other
big hook but they do have a couple
other big franchises like fantastic four
debuting
before avengers 5. so we'll get to that
stuff in a second
the quantum realm is something that they
barely started exploring in ant-man
and the wasp avengers infinity war and
avengers end game and the setup is that
not only can they use it to travel
through time and space
in different dimensions of the
multiverse per janet van dyne there are
also worlds upon worlds
whole civilizations quote unquote living
down there and she reveals that they can
use quantum energy to evolve humanity
into something
more like she's very vague about it but
she implies mutations so everyone post
your x-men memes
so there's just a whole lot going on
with that as a story device
in marvel phase 4 and marvel phase 5 for
them to use between all the other big
new marvel movies especially the
fantastic four
the negative zone alternate universes if
we're starting to talk about bringing in
legacy fox x-men characters for big
crossovers down the road like secret
wars
big multiverse movie crossovers number
three the big fantastic four movie
teaser in easter egg in all this is the
king the conqueror's real name
is nathaniel richards he's a descendant
of
reed richards from the distant future
thousands of years in the future but
he's still related to reed richards
the way he met reed richards for the
first time was kind of a roundabout way
but he debuted for the first time
in a fantastic four comic book so you
can kind of see how they're laying the
foundation for the mcu fantastic four
reboot movie
kevin feige's last big announcement
about that fantastic four movie was that
they had big plans for them in the mcu
and they wanted to reboot the franchise
making it super
important in a core piece of the future
of the marvel movies
and along the way through the marvel
phase 4 movies they just start laying
seeds and easter eggs for all the bigger
stuff down the road the same way that
they did with the infinity gauntlet and
thanos during the early marvel phase 1
and phase 2 movies
they started doing this during avengers
end game in a big way the main reason
why they used the quantum realm and time
travel is the solution for beating
thanos in
endgame was to establish the concepts of
time travel in multiple realities
then jumping around through time
fighting technically the same villain in
different time periods
also setting up the multiverse in a big
way through multiple timelines and
multiple realities
kang's big trick in the avengers comics
is that he fights the avengers in
multiple time periods simultaneously
using different versions of himself from
different parts of the timeline
for instance like i said his very first
appearance was in a fantastic four comic
it was fantastic for number 19
he debuted as a character calling
himself rama tut
he was a time travel villain posing as a
pharaoh ruling over ancient egypt
a year after that happened he took the
name kang the conqueror and appeared in
avengers number eight that was his first
big avengers crossover
then over the years different versions
of him from different parts of the
timeline with different identities
would cross over with the fantastic
foreign avengers having big fights
he's called himself nathaniel richards
because that was his birth name
kang the conqueror the scarlet centurion
immortus
and iron lad so this is where we get to
the iron man connection
what happened you mess with time it
tends to mess back
you'll see so for those of you wondering
if they'd ever do iron lad in a young
avengers disney plus series number two
the connection to iron man
and iron lad is that iron lad is sort of
the successor to iron man in a
roundabout way in the young avengers
comics
but really what's going on with the
character is that he's actually a
younger version of kane the conqueror
just
posing as iron lad there was a report
earlier this year that the other major
thing that they were going to do
in the ant-man 3 movie was setting up
the young avengers of the mcu
bringing that team together they already
have cassie lang's stature who's coming
back
they have the kate bishop hawkeye who's
showing up soon in the disney plus
series
there's wiccan and speed who are scarlet
witch and visions twins that are
supposed to debut in the wand division
series
and they have miss marvel whose disney
plus series they're going to be filming
next year
so they've already almost got a full
roster not including the other potential
new members they might put on that team
kang the conqueror was a major young
avengers time travel villain iron lad
was just posing as a team member during
that story as part of kang's larger time
travel plot
they haven't really said whether or not
the young avengers project would be
another disney plus series or if they do
it as a full-blown movie but they'll
talk more about that after all the other
new team member
characters debut in the mcu the number
one there was also a rumor that kang was
supposed to show up during the loki
disney plus series next year
now that they've officially cast him for
ant-man 3 what they'll probably wind up
doing
is instead just tease him with some
easter eggs helping set him up as a
bigger
threat in the multiverse in the timeline
the loki series is a time travel rick
and morty style
series with multiple realities the
person running the show is literally
from the rick and morty team
and get this more rick and morty in the
mcu cronenberg
the mcu the person who wrote the ant-man
script is also a writer from rick and
morty there's been other people from the
rick and morty show that have worked on
marvel movies before like dan harmon
did also do some work for the doctor
strange movie for a lot of their big
multiverse stuff
so you can kind of see the connection
there and even though we're talking
about time travel and supposedly rick
and morty isn't about time travel they
did that
during rick and morty season four so now
the metaphor just works a little bit
better
this is meant to be the loki that
escaped with the tesseract during
avengers end game he created a new
timeline where he wasn't captured by
thor
or taken back to asgard before thor the
dark world during the events of that
series he'll be traveling through
earth's history messing with different
major events like the avengers did
during endgame the place that he's in
during the marvel phase 4
trailer footage is in the time variance
authority's prison
that's why it reads tva on his prison
jumpsuit there and he's spewing about
burning the place to the ground
they're kind of like the time cops or
the time lords of the marvel universe
they mostly show up in the avengers in
the fantastic four comics to capture
people who mess with the timeline
so king the conqueror big fantastic four
villain being marvel's biggest time
travel villain would probably be
number one on their most wanted list
next to loki with the tesseract in the
space stone
but i'll do more videos for the loki
series when they release more footage
those episodes will release after the
falcon and winter soldier episodes in
the one division episodes are done
the black widow movie is still supposed
to come out in november this year we'll
get the first marvel eternals trailer
when that happens too
so of course i'll do videos for
everything as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
all those videos when i post them
but everyone click here for my new black
panther 2 chadwick boseman video
and click here for the boys season 2
episode 4 video with a whole bunch of
marvel easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!